veamos si podemos aprender algo sobre
las cifras significativas cifras
significativas también llamados dígitos
significativos la idea detrás de esto es
asegurarse de que cuando tengamos cierta
cantidad de dígitos estos no representen
más precisión de la que tenemos a qué me
refiero con precisión la precisión y las
cifras significativas en las mediciones
están determinadas por la unidad mínima
de los instrumentos de medición que
estamos usando por ejemplo si voy a
medir un lápiz y tengo un metro pues la
unidad mínima de ese metro va a ser un
centímetro voy a tener que medir ese
lápiz en centímetros y no más en cambio
con una regla de 30 centímetros ahí
tengo milímetros que también puedo usar
para medir va a ser mi unidad mínima por
lo que este lápiz lo voy a poder medir
en centímetros y 10 milímetros
aquí tenemos varios ejemplos para
identificar a las cifras significativas
y más adelante veremos con más detalle
cómo usamos esto en nuestros cálculos
después de estos ejemplos trataremos de
inferir algunas reglas la idea general
es identificar aquellos dígitos que me
dan información acerca de la precisión
de mi medida comencemos con esta primera
cifra punto 00 700
bueno aquí estas son las cifras
significativas tiene tres cifras
significativas y quizá los incómodos que
no estemos incluyendo estos ceros que
están después del punto decimal y antes
que este 7 pero no los incluyó porque a
pesar de que me ayudan a definir el
número no me dicen nada sobre la
precisión de esta medida para que
comprendan mejor eso imaginen que eso de
punto cero 0 700 está en kilómetros que
es lo mismo que 7.000 metros imaginen
que usamos un metro para medir esto y
que lo medimos hasta el último
centímetro y después se nos ocurrió
expresar esto en kilómetros ambos
números son iguales solo están
expresados en unidades diferentes viendo
éste 7.00 metros aquí queda mucho más
claro el por qué sólo tenemos tres
cifras significativas aquí estos ceros
después del punto decimal no son
significativos porque pueden desplazarse
dependiendo de las unidades
los números que en realidad dan la
precisión son este 700 y lo sabemos
porque están estos ceros a la derecha de
este 7 o de este edicto que no es ser
quien escribió esta cifra no tenía por
qué ponerlos a menos que nos quiera
indicar explícitamente hasta donde me
dio en este lado si sólo hubiera medido
los metros no hubiera puesto estos dos
ceros después del punto y lo hubiera
dejado como siete metros vemos la
siguiente cifra aquí pues con base en la
misma lógica vamos a decir que estas son
nuestras cifras significativas y son dos
que aquí lo puedo poner dígitos dígitos
significativos
aquí no incluimos el cero con base en la
misma lógica que acabamos de explicar si
estos por ejemplo fueran kilómetros
entonces tendríamos que son 52 metros y
aquí se ve las dos cifras significativas
no tomamos en cuenta aquellos ceros que
se encuentran a la izquierda de nuestro
primer dígito diferente de cero
y los que están a partir del primer
dígito diferente de 0 y todos los
dígitos a la derecha de este incluyendo
los ceros que estén intermedios veamos
el siguiente 370 punto y esta esa
cantidad y aquí el punto decimal si no
lo hubieran puesto no nos quedaría tan
clara la precisión de esta medida como
no pusieron nos dicen que me dieron
exactamente hasta 370 no lo redondearon
y el otro un kart
aquí tenemos tres cifras significativas
el 10 nuevamente aquí pusieron un cero a
la derecha del punto por lo que nos
dicen que me dieron hasta la décima más
cercana aquí también tenemos tres cifras
significativas
en estas 700 5.001 aquí nos dicen que me
dieron hasta la milésima más cercana
incluyendo los ceros
estos ceros porque forman parte de esta
medida pues se encuentran entre dígitos
diferentes de cero aquí todos los
dígitos que están escritos son seis son
cifras significativas este último es
ambiguo no se sabe si me dieron
exactamente 37 mil hasta la unidad más
cercana o si se me dio hasta el millardo
más cercano si ustedes ven una cifra así
sino un punto decimal solamente con esta
información podrían decir que sólo tiene
dos dígitos significativos para que
fuera menos ambiguo debería tener un
punto decimal aquí al final para indicar
que la precisión es exactamente de
37.000 y así tendría cinco dígitos
significativos